to Dancing with the Stars pros are ready
to say I do ET caught up with a couple
to hear how Maksim Chmerkovskiy pulled
off the surprise engagement to Penner
Murgatroyd without his family or friends
knowing i decided not to say it to
anybody no mom no dad I also wanted it
to be kind of like a surprise for
everybody everybody having an amazing
moment that is very unforgettable he
said now that his fiance is happy with
her massive sparkler max says PETA can
take care of the rest of the wedding
details maxxis said out loud that you
are in charge of all the details you
know when where how big all about with
that I want to I want to do it all I'm
cool with that he can just sit there and
turn up for the other day any idea when
is it going to be soon or we'd like you
to know yeah little busy right now yeah
very busy so big small lots of people
into that what do you think big if
you're wondering which moves will make
it to the couple's first dance as
newlyweds max joked will be sitting down